Any questions?
Point number 22.
We are having the complete contents
of this international Dawah training
program
recorded on 13 different 8K and 4K film
cameras
which would inshallah help hundreds
of millions of other Muslims worldwide
through satellite.
What is 8K, 4K? We'll discuss when we do
Dawah through satellite. Inshallah.
How many people know what is 4K and 8K?
What is 4K?
And 8K?
4K doesn't have 4,000 pixels. It has 8
million.
Anyway, we won't discuss that now. This
is not a wild guess.
Shoot a wild guess. Laga laga, mil gaya.
You got a direct hit. But 4K everyone
knows.
Who really knows what is 4K and 8K?
Raise your hand.
Okay, inshallah, we'll speak about it in
brief, not in detail, not now.
I think Dawah through satellite is on
the seventh day, if I'm not mistaken.
We'll deal with that, inshallah.
So, this is the unique feature of this
Dawah training program which wasn't
there earlier.
Earlier Dawah training program, the
objective wasn't as advanced as this.
Point number 23. The recording of this
international Dawah training program,
besides
being shown on satellite, will also be
the most important tool for conducting
Dawah training programs in different
parts of the world.
With help of the recording
even though the instructor is not
specialized in being a trainer, the
impact of the training would be more
than 50% of what you have done.
This is a very important factor
That this training program
the recording, besides being shown on
satellite channels,
will also act as the most important tool
for conducting the our training
programs.
Even though
the instructor may not be a specialist.
And this
came to my notice
last May.
Just about 7 months back, a very close
friend of mine who has assisted me in
many Dawah training programs and has
conducted many Dawah training programs.
We had a specialized session last May
only for
graduates of Medina University.
Only graduates.
Some were non-Medina.
Over staff, you know.
First training phase for 15 days. And
normally
I give a guest appearance.
Initially guest appearance was for 2
days out of 15 days, then it became 1
day, then it became half a day.
Last time it was only for 2 hours.
And the last day
when I wanted to find out, I have my
ways of finding out how the training is.
For me, even if I interact 1 hour with
the students, I can come to know the
effectiveness.
So, in the last session
I said I'll give 2 hours and I went
there. I asked the students, "How was
the training?" "Fantastic. Nothing.
We have not done this
anywhere in the world." And blah blah
blah. All happy.
Words.
What a training. We have done so many
trainings. Better than Medina
University. Blah blah blah blah blah.
When anyone does something, I like
checking. Like how I checked up 4K.
And I checked up
And they don't feel bad when I'm
checking.
I asked them one basic question.
And I asked that question to you, also.
Which are the three most important
factors
to be an effective day?
Who knows the answer?
Which are the three most important
factors to be an effective guy? Raise
your hand.
1 2 3 4
100%
Got it? 100%
A person is training for 15 days.
And do you know not a single Medina
graduate
gave even one answer from three.
Now see, I've not completed one day
also. And everyone is raising their
hand.
I did not complete even one day,
correct?
If you can't grasp these three things,
your training is not at all. Yes, it may
be 5% effective of my training. That 5%
was so good for them that they started
praising it to the sky.
And I was
very disappointed. One of the best
persons who have been with me for so
many years using the same notes.
It was mentioned in the notes. Not that
wasn't mentioned. If you don't have with
these three things
We have many trainers and their trainers
here also have taken many courses.
But the difference was that when we take
the training course for our students of
Islamic International School which we
did later on, we show my recording of
1999.
Because I feel the trainers are not that
trained.
But this person been with me for so many
years and trusted and traveled
throughout many countries in the world
with me, why does he require the
recording?
And it was a disaster.
It was a disaster
for me.
Find the people who even get 2% of the
training
are very happy because they don't know
what is the real training.
So 2% of this training also is so
effective that they started praising so
much.
That's the reason I thought I would edit
because nothing goes on air until I see
it. The training program we did in 1999,
I did not see it.
Unless I check it, it can't go on air.
So, I thought okay, what we'll do is
edit that. And we'll put it on air.
When I saw the quality, it was so bad.
It was the best that time.
In '99,
it was the best cameras available.
The best.
Normal thumb rule is that if you shoot
in the best cameras available, it can be
there for the next 10 years.
Sheikh Ahmad Deedat, he shot his
programs on the best
cameras available that time.
But, shelf life is
how many years?
10 years.
Today,
Peace TV shows
Ahmad Deedat's talks.
To upgrade 100 of I have spent more than
a million dollars because he's Sheikh
Deedat.
He's an icon.
It's a requirement. We have to do it
irrespective of the cost is.
Even after spending a million dollars,
we put a ticker.
Please excuse us for the quality. It is
the worst quality program showed on
Peace TV quality. Content-wise,
alhamdulillah, one of the best.
So, after spending more than a million
dollars, it is the worst quality.
Content-wise, Deedat is Deedat.
Alhamdulillah.
So, when I saw my quality of 1999,
16 years back,
just to tell you, these cameras we're
shooting with will inshallah be in the
market for more than 50 years.
For information,
just to give you a sample, no television
channel in the world has these cameras.
Peace be upon him.
When we shoot this,
I'm taking care
how long will I live? Allah knows how
long.
Will I live for a day or a year or 10
years? How long?
Allah knows the best. But, we want to
secure this inshallah minimum for the
next 50 years with Allah's help.
These cameras were also there at the
last time.
May Allah grant him Jannah.
But
what is the expense?
People will think it is israf.
Most of the people if they know the cost
of this Dawah training program, 99.9% of
the scholars will say it's israf.
Why? They aren't experts in the field of
satellite.
They are right.
If you have to divide the cost in 19
people or 20 people, one day you know
what it will cost.
Don't ask me the cost of this training
program. It's too expensive.
When you could spend a million dollars
for Sheikh Deedat to upgrade it,
you can imagine the cost of this
training program.
So, this training program the objective
is
to secure it in a format
which is the best available in the world
today. And for that, I have to give more
time for that than the training program.
That is the reason you will find me that
I'm more technically involved.
And once we secure it,
fine, your purpose is to gain knowledge.
You will gain knowledge.
These 20 dais that will be created
alhamdulillah sum alhamdulillah.
I want to create millions of dais. I'm a
wholesaler.
So, this program after being edited,
it will be used as a tool.
You can show it on screen.
And the instructor may not be that
effective also, no problem. It will do
its job.
The technology used.
And we'll discuss it more when we have
our
Dawah through satellite.
And you may have heard of the Peace
Conference. Who has heard of the Peace
Conference?
Peace Conference, most of alhamdulillah.
The Peace Conference alhamdulillah sum
alhamdulillah is the biggest Islamic
English conference in the world. The
technology, the
things you It is phenomenal. Broken
world records.
Just for information,
this Dawah training program,
alhamdulillah, will be more effective
than the Peace Conference.
Inshallah, if Allah wills.
Once this training program is secured,
it's like like the most important tool.
I need not
travel,
need not give time. Even if it has 50%
impact.
When the person gets 5% and he's
praising so much,
I don't even think it's 5%.
What will 50% do?
So, inshallah, pray to Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala that the objective of this
Dawah training program is fulfilled.
Point number 24.
The most important objective of this
particular training program is the
professional recording
of this international Dawah training
program, which will not only benefit the
20 participants attending, but also
hundreds of millions of Muslims
worldwide.
Point number 25. My mission of life is
peace
in every home.
And I pray to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
that may he make me
and Peace TV
and the recording of this international
Dawah training program instrumental
in making
peace enter every home.
Our beloved Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said,
which is Sahih Hadith,
as I Muslim,
that wherever the night and the day will
reach, inshallah, Islam will reach every
home.
I pray to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala that
may he make me,
Peace TV and the recording of this
international Dawah training program
instrumental
in making Islam enter every home.
This is one of the most important
objectives
of this training program.
Point number 26.
One of the main objectives of this
international training program is not
only to have a day
in every country.
Not only to have a day in every city of
the world.
Not only to have a day in every locality
of the world, but
to have at least one day
in most of the Muslim homes if not all.
The mission of this hour training
program. The objective is
that not to have a day in every country
though we selected days
participants from 10 countries. Last
time it was 14 countries.
The aim and objective is not only to
have a day in every country in the
world. Not only to have a day in every
city in the world. Not only to have a
day in every locality in the world, but
to have a day in most of the Muslim
homes at least one.
In most of the Muslim homes if not all.
And we know today
it is becoming more and more difficult
for a day to do the hour.
As time is passing
it's being more and more difficult, but
Allah has his way.
The hour also is becoming more and more
effective.
So we have to use
this technology.
The maximum damage done
today
to the image of Islam
is by the media.
We have to turn the tables over.
Inshallah. Use the media to make it the
most powerful tool to remove the
misconception and spread Islam in every
home inshallah.
This was in brief regarding the main
objectives of this international
training program.
We have two sessions pending.
One is the
of the Dawat e Islami program which has
already started.
And the second is
analyzing the expectations
of the participants.
The official
tea time is from
4:30 to 5:00.
I think we'll have a break
for the Asr Salah
from 4:15 to 4:30. And then we'll have a
break for tea from 4:30 to 5:00.
Inshallah, we'll resume
at
5:00.
And we will first do
the analysis of the expectations, which
is more important.
The introduction we'll either do it
after the Maghrib Salah
if time permits,
or we'll do it tomorrow, Inshallah.
We'll just see how the time goes. We'll
have a short break now for the Asr Salah
and for the tea break, Inshallah. We'll
resume sharp, Inshallah, at 5:00
for the last session.
>> All right, man.
All right, man.